don't know women they're known for lying
so you know that that's true believe no
women none of us 25 year old woman way
prettier than a 19 year old she does her
makeup better she's more developed she's
just hotter but she comes with an
opinion
[Laughter]
favorite Bible verse is when Jesus
Compares a woman to a dog
what up guys welcome to the judge pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
ring that notification Bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos like the video on your way and
let's get started so today I am going to
be reacting to John zurka making Myron
laugh for eight minutes straight so John
zurka um I would say it's probably the
funniest guy in the entire red pill that
guy is hilarious so he guests on fresh
and fit pretty pretty frequently and I
wanted to see yeah I wanted to see him
making him laugh so let's pull the
footage I was convinced I'm like these
guys hate me because I said fresh sounds
like he's got a sock in his mouth when
he talks
like that's why they're not having you
on and then what's your relationship
status I am single no so she's confirmed
did you not give me your phone number
earlier well you're not single I don't
remember you oh
where does a man get his value his
financial status that he has full
control over it but your hands are
around his scrotum and Men hate their
scrotum touch let go
why do you need that why do you have to
be Hillary Clinton I've never had an STD
okay no
[Music]
I [__] teenagers they don't have STDs
[__]
for me there's nothing harder than let's
say your fingering fingering and she's
about to come there's nothing harder
than calling her a loser when you're
doing it I don't know what I was
expecting when I clicked on this video I
don't know what I was expecting but it
wasn't that
oh dear oh gosh oh
the only thing harder than calling her a
loser as your fingering her is when you
mean it because if she lost her job that
day she's a [__] loser that day she
lost her job and you comfort her your
finger and you go you lost your job you
[__] suck at life they come so
[__] hard from the truth right in
person who he [__] runs with all
fours like a [__] animal
they do 20 hit pieces call people
rapists and you want that French sitting
cut everyone in the chat say his name
and call his mama that is true Adam
preached me to the hell out of Myron
they me too the hell out of that man I
actually it is so crazy when I figured
out the full story of what happened with
Myron and the way like Abba and preach
phrased it was like that Myron was
saying that girls had to sleep with him
to get on the show and it turns out that
girl like unsent a bunch of messages and
like it didn't show the full story and I
guess that girl even called him later to
apologize and it's so crazy because Ava
and preach like play the victims but
they just like edit [__] out yeah it's
like kind of crazy but I guess they make
a lot of money doing it I will say
though because of their content which
rhymes with the whole role
oh
yeah
Rich uses the [__] no the water to
watch your ass was something called yeah
he uses it to like lick the water
my name is Diana I'm 29 years old wait
39 20 29. okay we're gonna need
subtitles for her
you just don't give a [__] where are you
from Diana
um yeah I don't know women they're known
for lying so you know that that's true
believe no women none of us of all women
no I asked the boys I said he's gonna
say the same thing yeah don't believe
any woman that's the new hashtag most of
them are lying [__] bro you bro I
don't know anything about preach it's
true though honestly I was thinking
about this I'm like why do we lie about
male and female nature and I and I I
came to this I I was thinking real hard
and I came to this conclusion is that it
would make us look bad and we don't want
to look bad so we're like yeah women and
men are equally truth tellers nah uh-uh
men are much more honest than women
because we just get in this like weird
hysteria we'll like see some propaganda
and just like complete we're like yeah
the world is completely sexist racist
and homophobic all cause I watched some
sad video on Tick Tock I don't know what
it is about us we're just kind of we're
like kids I don't know it's like you you
show a kid like they convince kids to
believe in Santa Claus and you know
we've convinced women to believe in
sexism even though we live life on easy
milk easy mode it's so crazy Apple's the
homosexual
okay he snaked eight YouTubers and these
[__] are too afraid to come outside
[__] I'll expose you ladies
there's room for improvement and I think
you guys are all going to get married
like I believe in you guys okay all
right okay that's nice all right all
right because it's almost the end of the
show we gotta start lying to [__] them
right
no okay this is so true this is so true
because guys will come on and cap they
will cap so hard and you know they're
just capping because they want to get
laid so you know I appreciate the
honesty zirka
[Music]
the first time in thousands of years
women closed the gap on cheating with
men and they're 10 times less horny than
us these are [__]
no I was thinking about it I'm like we
have a whole society of like 10 percent
of men that are just living life they're
like I don't know why you guys are
complaining about the [__] we love
these hoes and the other ninety percent
of men are just like lonely and they're
like damn it I have to marry one of
these ran through hoes to get sick this
is a terrible life and that is just a
bunch of hoes go ahead oh on this how
the [__]
steroids of testosterone and they close
the gap bro wait oh my gosh I have been
trying so hard to figure out something
women are better at I have been I have
been all week no month I have been
thinking I've been thinking so hard
obviously not I haven't been thinking as
good as a guy right but but I've been
thinking so hard and I'm like women we
have to be better at something as a
group like I found out we were more
likely to kill the infants and the
elderly and I was like oh [__] we can't
even nurture and then I find out that
the men the men are having sex with
transsexuals we're not even getting
[__] better than men like like famous
men are getting caught having sex with
[__] they would rather have sex with
a guy dressed up as a woman rather than
a woman ladies this is not good this is
not good but thank you zerka you've
helped me think of something women are
better at cheating we're better cheaters
we are better too right wouldn't you
agree with that we're better cheaters
yeah thank you everyone's thank you
thank you hi strength horny testosterone
we do them in everything the one thing
they beat us in is being a [__] what
the [__] what was it like me in The Rock
was he cool he's a homosexual bro
I hate to do this to you bro but he's
not gonna come on here because that
guy's a liberal homosexual [__] turned
on Trump as if that guy's not masculine
what the [__] he's a total liberal bro
100 he wouldn't like any of us
she reminds me of those women who don't
shave the bush
no no we both have that problem
do you have tits no I don't oh you are
just a disaster
she makes up an allegation so I worked
with horse for four years and if you
count nightclub bouncing I worked with
[__] for like almost 10 years right so
I know the [__] nature of a [__] and
they've never done an allegation against
me because then a million [__] will
come out and say no he's a good guy he
actually I have a low libido so I'm no
creeps like no wonder he has allegations
against him and this [__] is is mad
because I didn't [__] her the [__] is
28 and I have an 18 year old on my lap
do the math [__] what the [__]
that's not good though it's not good to
move that Reckless because like the the
government believes [__] right and she
said you know that's what I think I
never understand why we look at a [__]
is credible like all these women that
are coming out against Tate are literal
sex work they're literal sex workers
it's like these are the quality that
we're gonna all right all right fat ugly
bowling ball smiling at you with fat
ugly bowling ball with two shoes at the
bottom yeah mine I have an interesting
theory of why guys like uh younger women
right so like my phone freezes from all
the women who text me right oh my gosh
it's unfortunate but now look at this I
genuinely put me on a lie detector test
on God I find a 25 25 year old woman way
prettier than a 19 year old she does her
makeup better she's more developed she's
just harder she comes with an opinion
I'm not joking man women suck at
everything compared to men literally
everything even sucking dick some
[__] gay dudes right or or gay dudes
I don't know I don't know I'm just
saying I've heard oh my gosh this is
just what I was saying they're picking
the [__] over us oh my gosh it's
just embarrassing like I just look at us
as a group you know and I'm not saying
there's not amazing individual women
okay so can't like guys can we just
please don't say that I don't say
there's exceptions you know I'm a big
I'm a big Candace Owens Stan I'm a big
big Candace fan Brett Cooper awesome
another one it's like I can my mom
pretty cool lady but as a group though I
just like look it up and when we have
more only fans workers than teachers now
when we you know have a 50 divorce rate
and we're like leaving all the men when
I I see you guys eyes using your kids is
basically accessories on Instagram I'm
just like disappointed like I'm like
guys can we can we do anything some of
the teachers have only fans as well yeah
like and then you get those pastors that
are like female Pastor porn stars yeah
you haven't seen that they're like
they'll like do a whole Pastor thing and
then like they had no only fans I mean
they put it away when they start
preaching but it's like or they'll be
preaching and then go into it it's like
female nature guys we'll do anything for
attention it's so crazy I you know what
came first men seeking sex or women
seeking attention I will die on this
hill I will die on the hill that women
will seek attention before men will seek
sex I know this is crazy but look on the
streets walk down the street do you see
more men asking for sex or women taking
their clothes off it's like the men
imagine being a Christian man in today's
Danny imagine being like a guy that like
genuinely wanted to be celibate how hard
would it be would these women walking
around naked all these half naked chicks
on TV and you can't even go to work it's
like you go to work and the women are
dressed like [__] too you can't even
avoid it but and it's almost I was
thinking about this I'm like is it
harassment for a woman to be like half
naked at work is it kind of harassing
the men a little bit he thinks Elizabeth
removed Christianity out of it this is
something I have been struggling with a
lot like because of everything I'm
trying to get into the whole boxing
training and all of that I'm literally
just trying to like streamline the
things I consume the content but you
can't even go on the internet today and
not see soft porn like everywhere you
scroll there's porn everywhere there's
women shaking your asses showing their
boobs like you can't just get away from
that thing and like I literally spend
half of my mornings blocking pages on
Instagram just to filter out because
people say no it depends on what you
watch if you look at my explore page
there's little actually nothing that has
nothing to do with everything that's on
there is about boxing or Fitness or
something but when I scroll through my
tear I will still see some girl naked
shaking up shaking her butt or something
like you can't get away from it no you
know what's crazy I'd never seen porn
before I got Twitter but all these
freaking only fans workers I would [__]
on only fans and they would tweet at me
they're only fans [__] and I'm like no I
didn't want to see that or like when I
was talking about adam22 they would like
tweeted me pictures and videos I was
like I've been traumatized but it's like
literally you can't like sex is so in
our face now and I just and I went to
Vegas oh my God it's so bad in Vegas all
the girls just have stickers on their
boob they walk around topless and I was
spanked I was walking down the boardwalk
this chick spanked me because she like
tried to talk to me and I was like
um okay this chick spanked me and I was
just like what the [__] I was assaulted
I'm gonna use the feminist words I was
assaulted and I was thinking about it
I'm like a man has never done that to me
just like walked up to me and like that
would be weird but this chick gets a
pass and I was like if she did that to
me like women assault like I think women
sexually like if we're gonna say like
sexual assault right now it's like a
feminist word but if we're gonna say
that is like touching unwanted like
touching I think women do it to men more
than men do it to women nowadays it's
almost like women we love the attention
from men but they've put all these legal
tools so we can't get it like um you
know like men are walking away from
relationships because the marriage laws
are too bad men are walking away from
like even like hooking up with chicks
they're like I gotta be careful and make
sure I get her consents they don't want
to get you know an allegation or
whatever I was thinking about it but
then it makes the women crazy they're
like oh God the men are pulling back let
me take off my clothes and that's why we
have all these naked chicks and it's
kind of crazy once you like see it you
can't unsee it because all the Trad cons
will be like let's go back to
traditionalism just find you like a nice
lady and the guys are like where and you
know it's like there's unicorns but
they're unicorns you know
um and then it's like what is the
average guy gonna find a unicorn because
men operate on like probabilities not
possibilities they're like probably not
they're like this is real life you know
where I'm I'm not gonna find a virgin 22
year old like anyways my point is this I
I really do think that assault like like
it's almost like harassing Men by being
naked like why don't we have to look at
these naked chicks I I just don't
understand statistics three billion
women on earth and they can't figure
that equation they're so stupid yo as
soon as we come yo as soon as we come
leave the [__] house and go for a
walk we never want to be around you when
we come go for a walk go to the dog
house go wherever the [__] you gotta go
and they always want to cuddle and [__]
and you have to do Aftercare so she
doesn't call your rapist out there but
look if a man comes to some
get the [__] up [__]
wow look at Myra tank don't [__] out you
know how [__] how little we need you
when we're gay we make even more money
I'm sorry who rules the world wait is
that true gbt rainbow flag corporations
and all that
I'm telling you guys we don't need you
we just like to be inside of you darling
I love to be inside of all you I love
[__] you guys but you're useless you
don't bring resources you work four
years and expire right you'll you need
men to live so I don't I don't need you
for [__] I need you for [__] you're a 38
and never been married
but my favorite Bible verse is when
Jesus Compares a woman to a dog wait
does he really
laughs
they did not teach me this one in
Catholic way yes he did he said it's not
good she answers yet even so Lord he
calls the Jews children she calls them
Master he called her a dog she accepts
the office of a dog as if she had said I
cannot lead leave the table of my Lord
to mock from the club you're getting
blocked period if she [__] Myron fresh
John Circle even that homosexual Destiny
if you have an identity and they these
guys talk about I love their content
women they can't even do that they can't
even kill them so they're [__] suck
at everything
recently I [__] this 18 year old I
only [__] teenagers right 18 19. what
the [__] [__] [__] bro you guys
don't [__] teens look at these guys bro
he spent mine when's the last time you
got an 18 year old be honest what [__]
you guys Let Me Drown here bro the
[__] cocaine is getting to your
[__] right I feel like it's weird
that you get turned on by girls crying
now you've made it personal you attacked
my Coke
video
[Music]
wow you know you can really see why
Circa is blowing up in the red pill he's
hilarious I mean that's funny
um but let me get let me know if you
guys have any other zurica Clips you
want me to react to or whoever else yeah
let me know uh in the comments guys
don't forget to subscribe I really think
we need to bring more comedy edgy jokes
back because honestly since women have
gotten into things we just police
everything we tell men what to say and
how to say it and I just think it's sad
I think men should be able to make jokes
and I don't think there's any subject
really that should be off limit um but
now let me know what you guys think in
the comments subscribe to the channel
I'll talk to you next time